welcome to my video series of cell
signaling and communication in this
video series I would describe the
importance of intracellular and
intercellular communication the types of
receptor the detailed signaling
mechanisms and how cell signaling
pathways controlled overall physiology
so if you haven't yet subscribed my
channel please hit that subscribe button
and don't forget to like we don't like
to stay in isolation rather we prefer to
talk to each other and make new friends
and build new networks just like us
cells don't like to stay in isolation
their together form tissues and these
diesel issue organizations form several
organs like here the hepatic cells from
hepatic tissue which ultimately give
rise to deliver not only organs organ
system need to interact with one another
in order to form a large system known as
organ systems so organ systems should
connect each other and thereby
controlling the complex cellular
physiology now we like to stay connected
with each other and communicate with our
friends and families and we do that by a
cell phone mobile Facebook Twitter
whatsapp etc but have you ever thought
there are so many cell types in our body
how do they communicate to each other
have you ever thought how our brain
cells communicate with the muscle cells
and tell them to contract have you ever
wondered that how our brain cells tell
liver cells to secrete digestive enzymes
and hormones which are important for
digestion so if you are thinking about
this let me tell you that there are
several communication modes used by the
cells in our body one type of long-range
communication is endocrine communication
we're the secretive messenger or the
secreted signal is traversing a long way
via the bloodstream and reaching its
target cell when it is receptive by the
receptors on its cell surface second
type of short distance signaling is
known as paracrine signaling but the
signaling molecules are working in a
shorter range whereas there are other
signalling modes known as autocrine
signaling which acts upon the cell
itself
now all these signaling paradigms and
cellular signaling keeps us a heavy
organism and keeps all our organ system
going but if it doesn't happen so we
would die so which is pathetic now let's
say we have ingested a tasty doughnut as
a result our blood glucose level would
increase as you can predict that our
pancreas would secrete insulin to lower
the blood glucose level but wait a
minute how does our pancreas knows that
the blood glucose level has increased
who had told the pancreas cell that our
blood glucose level has increased all
these details or all these mechanistic
views could be understood in light of
cell signaling now if you are thinking
about all of these things stated in the
video let me tell you while you are
watching the video your you are getting
visual and auditory cues which are
transformed into electrical signals
inside the neurons of your brain which
is incredible how your sensory
modalities is giving rise to electrical
implant electrical impulses and that is
decoded by the brain but indeed these
signals are decoded by the brain and
brain is responsive to all these signals
and giving rise to output signals which
controls all our organ system together
and that's how we our body is
functioning so that's why we need to
understand the basics of cell signaling
cell signaling starts with a signaling
molecule signaling molecules
receptive by a receptor on the cell
surface or maybe sometimes inside the
cells and then the signal generated by
this signal and receptor interaction
would be relayed downstream by a
specific molecule or all or by a relay
of molecules which would ultimately give
rise to a similar level response
that's why understanding how these
receptors are interacting with the
ligand how the ligand is giving rise to
receptors conformational change how the
receptor is internal part of the
receptor is interacting with several
other signaling molecules to give round
rise to cellular processes is very
important now the whole complexity is
dependent upon different type of
receptor there are different type of
receptors and different type of choices
present for the cell by which it can
convey its message to other cell or it
can convey its message to the deep in
the nucleus and the ligands that there
is receptor interact with are very
different
not only the big ants the intermediate
players the downstream effectors all are
very different together which makes a
huge complexity very often it has been
seen the intermediate players are not
isolated they are also interacting
between each other making a huge network
and this is how cross talking between
signaling pathways are happening which
give rise to complexity in cellular
physiology and all these things account
for huge complexity inside the cells and
as if cell is a huge factory where
several claim on several molecules
several downstream molecules are workers
of a big factory which are working with
a synchronous communicating with each
other giving rise to complex cellular
processes that's why learning about cell
signaling and how cell signaling can
affect human physiology is very
important aspect so if you liked my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to subscribe and share a moment
with your friends and help me to grow
thinking